ainsi klaus barbie at il été transféré
du fort montluc à la prison de saint
joseph à lyon 1 c'est notre deuxième
titre à la une un transfert s'est
réalisé dans la nuit henri une semaine d
hésitation de la part des autorités
un transfert guidé par le souci d'une
plus grande sécurité pour ceux détenus
exceptionnel danielle cattelin non
prison militaire de montluc dont deux
heures trente hier soir une centaine de
crs dont la 48e compagnie isole le
portail une dizaine de cars de police
bloquent des rues adjacentes la
circulation est détournée
le dispositif est en place le transfert
de klaus barbie jusqu'à la tenue secret
peut avoir lieu
23 heures les portes de la prison sous
des voitures de plantes niveau courbon
sorte en trombe et se dirige vers les
quais du rhône
quelques minutes après klaus d'art
d'entrer dans sa nouvelle prise par an
la prison saint joseph est un ensemble
de cinq bâtiments un centre de lyon près
de la gare de perrache
klaus barbie qui occupe une cellule de
10 mètres carrés équipée d'un sanitaire
est totalement isolé les dix neuf autres
des plus de ce bâtiment été transférés
et 24 gardiens assurent la surveillance
et la sécurité du criminel de guerre
selon la préfecture du rhône ce
transfert était décidée par mesure de
sécurité et pour des raisons sanitaires
la prison saint joseph possède une
infirmerie un oeil aux équipes mais que
celle de main